we were at like a dinner party and
somebody was talking about andy circus
playing playing gollum in lord of the
rings and uh and how like just how
brilliant andy circus's performance was
and she said yeah no
it's all they had to do was hit the
golem button
[Laughter]
nina what are some older movies
with special effects that still hold up
i had to double check what the name of
the topic was
what's your pick
is this real
yeah we're going no it's okay
we're not doing it again just go
okay
um anyway
smooth intro as always
um so my pick for so older was tough i
didn't want to read a bunch of comments
that were like you're too young to
discuss movies at all you child or
whatever so
context i'm 30 years old this movie
feels old to me because i remember
watching it on a
two-part vhs tape where it would stop in
the middle and you'd have to change it
out for the other tape and that feels
that's pretty old that'll that feels old
enough so i think what it is i think i
think you do too it is go ahead
one of the rings
no it's so close it's titanic i almost
picked lord of the rings because lord of
the rings has some of the best cgi like
ever but it's too new i was like in in
the 2000s like it was 2001 two and three
and i was like that's still that's a
little not old enough so i went all the
way back to 1997. so no i mean titanic i
would not say is um my favorite movie of
all time but i did re-watch it recently
um
and it holds up pretty it held up better
than i thought it did
um you know
k winslet and dicaprio are good for
their age and stuff and like the romance
subplot is kind of
pokey and stupid but the sinking of the
ship is really cool and the effects that
james cameron used in that are mostly
like they're like half practical half
cgi i found this really cool
um article that i will send you both a
link to where it's from roger ebert like
when the movie came out and it's
something that i didn't know
where in order to do like those big
sweeping shots where you look at people
and they're on the boat he
filmed a model of it and then he cgi'd
people onto the model so he didn't have
to worry about the boat looking fake and
i was like that's pretty cool that's
very innovative that's a great mix of
practical cgi it's really smart it's
really cool and obviously like the the
building out of the huge set to you know
recreate the sinking in real time like i
mean he almost drowned half his cast
like it was a very realistic they all
got food poisoning great directors too
despite the pc pcp spiked clam chowder
was a very different incident but it's
still a great a great hollywood good
performance out of an actor you spike
that's true
that's why billy zane was so good he was
on pcp the whole time
my god mystery solved i apologize that's
what he did that's what he did for his
back to the future edition they're like
no exactly
yeah you're not you're not on enough pcb
so yeah magic that was missing from the
phantom
[Laughter]
solved another another movie mystery
look at us
so uh yeah i mean i don't i don't think
it's i don't need to like really really
sell anyone on the special effects and
titanic still being good they still look
good because there it's a lot of
practical stuff they went to
enormous lengths to build this
ridiculous set to the likes of which
nobody's ever seen they thought the
movie would flop it made all of the
money and won all of the oscars so like
nice vindication in the end that the
work that went into those effects was
totally worth it it's a really good
example james cameron being
the effects guy
um we've got two two items on our list
here older movies with special effects
that still hold up one of them is
terminator 2 uh judgment today which is
which is a great pick for this list
because again that's a james cameron
movie i think that must have been what
92
i think so
like real early in the 90s comparatively
and again that's a great
that movie just like titanic has this
great blend of practical effects and
early cgi where yeah i mean if you're
picking out the problems with the cgi
here and there you're going to find
problems but
yeah the titanic is a really dumb moment
where a guy falls into an engine and it
looks terrible like it looks really bad
but the most of these are perfect yeah
right i mean it's going to happen right
right so it's james cameron is like for
the majority of his career all of his
all of his special effects heavy movies
most of them i'll say really do hold up
in this great great way
another one in that same vein that's on
this list
is jurassic park which also has that
great blend of practical effects and
early cgi and one of the reasons why it
holds up so well i think all of the
items on this list that we're going to
talk about today either the ones that
you bring yeah it's an aliens on the
list as well
alien alien is on the alien we're sorry
yeah right yeah then yeah but you're
absolutely right aliens could also be on
this list right all all practical
effects no secrets at that point right
um but again like everything that we
think holds up is largely because they
actually did it for real and they got
expo exactly and like as much as i'm not
a huge fan of like every christopher
nolan thing that he's ever done like a
lot of his movies will look great in 30
40 years because he relies so heavily on
practical stuff tom you were going to
say a thing
i mean it kind of yeah i
i'm a huge practical effect fan i think
most people are it's it's just it's it's
a cool thing to get to
look at somebody made this rubber
monster and they made it come to life
in a way that at least like tricked you
for a second to make you forget that
you're watching a movie if you're doing
it right what i loved about jurassic
park is that yes so much of it is
done with practical effect uh the stan
winston studio made these incredible
creatures the the the t-rex that they
used is this 9 000 pound uh hydraulic
monster and it's incredible to watch
uh when when you look at the thing
behind the scenes and all the work that
went into it and they they they had to
pioneer new technologies to create this
thing it's it's really amazing
but also when you look at the at the
behind the scenes if you get a chance go
to the stan winston school website and
look up behind the scenes on them making
the the t-rex because it's astonishingly
clear
that if they hadn't shot it right it
would have looked like tammy in the
t-rex it would have looked like it was
like a very fancy b-movie it takes it
takes a director that's pretty good like
say steven spielberg to make it work
he's got experience with faulty monster
animatronics right like which the story
behind jaws is crazy right the story
behind jaws is that they i'm sorry tom
you go ahead no yeah you're absolutely
right yeah the the uh the the shark and
jazz bruce uh mm-hmm
what did he call he he had a nickname
for it i don't think we're allowed to
say it it worked
i don't think we are
but then like the the amount of stuff
that could have gone wrong and kind of
did go wrong while they were shooting
the t-rex scene in that movie uh
if you watch carefully when uh when it
goes down at the um the moon roof yeah
on top of the kids and it the face
just lunges at it and if you watch
carefully you can see one of its teeth
falling out like the the thing is
falling apart as they're shooting it
yeah it wasn't designed to shoot in the
rain apparently so like it took on
hundreds of pounds of water weight like
as they were shooting and blowing up
like a sponge yeah the weight was too
much for the hydraulics to handle so the
thing would just start moving by itself
without
control
yeah no it's amazing if i can to just
loop back a second back to jaws right
this is a movie that the special effects
really hold up because jaws even though
it's a fake robot shark you only see it
sometimes and the reason is because it
never worked and that's why
spielberg shot so much of the movie
without showing the shark it's that
classic everyone talks about this i'm
not saying anything new or revolutionary
but everyone talks about how one of the
reasons why jaws works so well is
because you almost never see the monster
that you're that you're afraid of but
even
the tension and he only did it because
he only did it because the shark didn't
work
that's interesting though because all
the examples that we're talking about
we're talking about titanic uh jurassic
park alien uh terminator 2 like in all
these examples these are really tense
high stake movies right where you're
like on the edge of your seat and in any
one of them if the effects didn't hold
up today you would be completely removed
from it right you'd be like well that
dinosaur looks like a crappy fake and
and i don't ever want to watch jurassic
park again and instead we're still like
oh my god are they going to eat the kids
like
you still get that panicky
moment
when you watch it because the effects
are just so good yeah fingers crossed
but like
maybe it'll end differently this time
yeah i i jumped i jumped ahead though
tom did you want to tell us what your
pick was oh my pick was jurassic park it
was 100 jurassic park because i think i
think that it is it's such a remarkable
example of the fact that any movie like
no matter how much effort love and
professionalism goes into it it's one
person who's not great at their job away
from
looking terrible and uh
everybody had to be firing on all
cylinders for that movie to work and it
worked
yeah and they
like you you go and you watch just the
subtle way that they'll switch from
animatronic to cgi it's it's incredibly
well done even the way that they frame
all of
these monsters that it it's it's wildly
beautiful and especially
compared to and not the not to get
through negative but man that last
jurassic world
was just such what trash i was actually
gonna say too like i'm probably gonna
not this is probably not a popular
opinion but like titanic's special
effects have aged better than avatar
special effects which i think sure
no i didn't want to get too deep into
the avatar that was why i was saying
most of his movies because even at the
time i was just like i'm watching a
video game yeah i i don't i don't i did
not enjoy avatar but
i also think the special effects like
don't have not held up that well because
it's all
cgi and it just doesn't that doesn't
work for me as much as like meshing
these two things we're talking about
together practical effects are so
so important and it's not like it's not
like all practical effects are good and
all movies with practical effects are
good and all movies do practical effects
well and it's always better that's not
the case but if you get pros and you get
people who really know what they're
doing and you get really good filmmakers
and like imagine if inception had been
mostly cgi it wouldn't have been as fun
when you know that joseph gordon-levitt
is in a box that moves and is doing this
fight scene like it it you it lends
something to the movie that you really
can't do with a computer
yeah i i don't know i i feel like we've
kind of gotten to the point like you
look at the behind the scenes on any
marvel movie and you'll spot stuff that
you didn't realize with cgi
sure yes anytime the vision is on screen
yeah
no that a lot of the stuff that they're
doing now is getting really really
really good but that's also again like
when you see the vision on screen he is
a practical effect there's still a guy
there they're just painting him did you
right versus if they made like
if they made the vid uh vision out of
cgi entirely or whatever right you'd be
like oh it's just it's a computer it
sucks so i think right they're doing the
gollum smeagol thing where they're
sticking
tennis balls to a really good actor yeah
exactly yeah it's tracy jordan as
garfield
and by the way i want to say i don't i
don't want to be like completely crappy
on computer-generated effects because
the other movie i thought of that but i
didn't want to bring it up because i
felt like a gimme was the first toy
story which still looks
freakishly unbelievably good and i can
only imagine like i was a i was a kid
when it came out and i remember seeing
it in the theater and it was like a
bunch of kids and a bunch of parents and
i'm sure the kids were like yay and the
adults were like how did they do this
like why does this look so good my
brother was really into the toy story
movies because he was really into the
computers he's like how'd they make this
movie yeah i mean
it looks it could stack up against most
pixar movies today which is nuts
yeah
yeah tom you were gonna say something
we're steamrolling you today no no i i i
i was i always feel bad
taking a dump on on on cgi because i
know that it's so much work i
i know a lady back in the day who who
used to be a professional digital artist
who like worked on movies and tv shows
and
my favorite way that she used to
describe it we were at like a dinner
party and somebody was talking about
andy circus
playing playing gollum in lord of the
rings and uh and how like just how
brilliant andy circus's performance was
and she said yeah no
because all they had to do was hit the
golem button and that that's what
that's right
just the immense amount of work that can
go into
right stuff the people that go i don't
know
that's the thing about
cgi these days too which is that like
what you said tom like you see the
behind the scenes stuff on these marvel
movies and things that are effects that
you had no idea were effects like
bucky's arm on winter
you know like little things like that
where
you only you know
some of the stuff on this list that
we're going to talk about in a second
with practical effects you know that
they're practical effects you know that
it's stan winston doing it and you can
say wow look at that that looks so
insane that looks so real and creepy and
gross but with the cgi thing
a lot of the really effective stuff that
they do is stuff you never notice it's
that's exactly right that's the point is
that the point is stuff that you will
never notice and it's uh
it's one of the first things that i
noticed in wanda vision that bummed me
out was uh
there's a shot where
it's it's a long shot of vision walking
across a field i think he's on his way
to like the the force field barrier
thing for the first time
and you get you get your first really
good look at him in the full outfit the
full vision ensemble and
you can tell that he's wearing rubber
pants the guy's wearing like
loose-fitting rubber pants that are just
folding with every step that he takes
and you realize this this is the sort of
thing
that somebody had to go in and digitally
paint out in every other movie that he's
been in that they just didn't have the
time or the budget to do on this tv show
or that just somebody didn't think of
doing
wow well i mean let's not let's not
forget like the second time i brought
this movie up on this show but like the
great cats cgi debacle where you know
the studio is like we want this movie
two months early like work 80 hours a
week and kill yourselves trying to get
it done and then it still ends up with
like a human hand and a wedding ring in
it because there just was not and
there's a lot of like weird like faces
that don't match things because they did
they did not have the time it's like
and then james corden and rebel rebel
wilson get up make fun of them at the
oscars and make fun of them for a movie
that they ostensibly had more to do with
being bad than the cgi yes i would
strongly agree with that but yeah it was
like they overworked people who were
frankly better at their better at that
job than that movie deserved and yeah no
and so i'm just gonna
you know back up
you know tom's thesis statement about
pressing the gollum button which is a
great one you know it's like
these all take so much work i could
never do it all all due respect
so a few of the other items on this list
that i really wanted to talk about i you
know to revisit terminator 2 there's so
many amazing shots where again that's
like the early the early early early cgi
getting used in movies and it looking
amazing because james cameron was so
good at finding ways to blend the the
digital with the practical like when you
know
um you know they they built
you know rubber things for when the
t-1000 is cut in half and he's like what
you know like yeah screwed up looking
but you you do it you you know the way
that you edit it together the way that
you shoot it it all works together um
another one that's on this list that i
really really like is the thing
um
we're recording this right before
halloween so it's appropriate this is
going up after halloween happy halloween
uh happy thanksgiving everybody um the
the new year i don't know when will this
happen happy new year happy presidents
day um the thing is one of those movies
where
everything in it is gross and disgusting
and horrible but everything looks so
cool anyway the point is everything in
that movie looks super real even the
stuff that's unreal it's terrifying it's
exciting and it all
really holds up there's that scene where
um he's trying to the the doctor's
trying to revive the guy with the um
with the paddles and he puts his hands
in the guy and his torso opens up like a
mouth and then bites his arms off
and it's just one of these and it's a
great jump scare it's hilarious but it's
also terrifying
and everything in that movie is just
absolutely like a classic i don't like
scary movies it'll be a long time before
i see the thing again because
it's scary um way too scary for me
you got to watch it though it's so so
good it's just so nina you got to watch
it it's just a great movie i'll watch it
like 11 a.m on a sunday or something
watch it with friends watch it with
friends
watch it in the day so it doesn't freak
you out too much let me text all my
friends do you want to come over and
watch the thing
they'd probably be like yeah that movie
rules watch it three times yeah another
one on this list is the original blade
runner 1982 really good effects i see i
wanted to talk about that one but it's
one of those ones that
they've redone it so many times that i
don't
know if i've seen the original effect
that's you know and star wars is on this
list too the original star wars it's
gonna mention it
but like try watching the original star
wars it's nearly impossible to find an
original version with the original
effects
so but you know what what does kind of
last a lot of the ship battles that were
still done practically those still exist
and those are still really really
impressive the exorcist is on this list
which is great alien which we mentioned
yeah and then jurassic park the one
that's not on this list that i wanted to
bring up um is a movie that we've
brought up recently as well that i've
brought up recently again another john
carpenter jam
big trouble in little china this movie
is bonkers and has crazy magic crazy
creatures
and
three gods who all die and one dies
because he i think if i'm if i'm correct
in interpreting the scene he just gets
so mad he's just so mad that he
literally blows up but he doesn't like
blow up he like
blows up and then explodes it's just
it's one of those effects that that is
just so it's it's um it's iconic you
know to use a lame term but it's it is
it's it's one of those great things that
uh that i love
so yeah
any other movies that we wanted to talk
about before we uh
say goodbye i i think the john carpenter
thing like his aesthetic
it never really struck me as
he wanted to make the most real looking
thing
just kind of the most effective
uh
looking weirdness and then that's that's
how i felt about so i felt about the
thing like
you were saying that the monster always
looks real and i don't know if he always
does like when the spine creature pops
at like
i mean you can always tell
you can always tell it's not necessarily
real
right but
there is there's the visceral nature of
it being in the room with the people
you know and seeing it with actual light
and shadow and actual movement in the
room
with the filmmaking on display there it
just works for me another example that i
thought about um that's pretty great are
the two gremlins movies
you know it's nothing more than really
good puppets
but the way that they use them with the
exception of maybe one shot in the
original gremlins that stop motion and
looks like crap right now because it's
all the gremlins walking along the
street in stop-motion animation that's
not good but everything else it's like
like in gremlins two
in gremlins two there's a scene where
all the gremlins are in the building
they're all getting rained down on by
water nina have you seen gremlins two
two i was a kid a new batch
oh go back re-watched gremlins too
i'm not even joking it's uh it's so good
expectations
they're all getting the water dumped on
them from the sprinkler system and they
zoom in on the on the bubbles on their
back
and the little teeny gremlin puffs so
they have to build this giant
bubble
for a tiny little gremlin puppet to be
in to simulate the tiny little teeny
tiny baby gremlin that's being born it's
gross and horrible they've got the big
spider gremlin in there you got your
vegetable gremlin you got all the
gremlins it's great movie gremlins watch
gremlins that's the end hulk hogan
stares into your soul through the tv
screen it's pretty good colgan the most
impressive special effect in the whole
movie yeah they made him seem like a
real person
definitely the most expensive
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe this is my job
[Music]